[Music]
margot robbie is back and we already
have a first look and kind of a teaser
for i got to read this because it's a
mouthful birds of prey and the
fantabulous emancipation up one harley
quinn rolls off the tongue rolls right
off the knife so a superhero team of
ladies are coming together to fight
these guys and you know what say what
you will about Suicide Squad I'm one of
the few people that really really liked
it but Harley Quinn was clearly the best
part of that she deserves her own
franchise seven movies a series a a
sequel a deal a book deal a blog and so
I'm really excited for her to just kind
of be emancipated I guess I was not
expecting to wake up on a Monday morning
and to be able to see that I didn't even
know they started filming it's a lot for
a Monday so the fact that they gave us
that teaser although it was only 19
seconds it had a lot but we do get like
a whole crop of new characters that go
really really fast yes so let me break
it down let's kind of break it down okay
jurnee smollett Bell as Black Canary
okay this is why I'm most excited about
because I am an arrow watcher so I've
seen many iterations of Black Canary on
the CW series I love that in this tiny
little clip of her that she's holding a
microphone because I think that's such a
cool interpretation because of course
she has her canary cry which kind of
incapacitates I understand yes so I was
very excited to see that so kudos to me
if you showed me that picture and you
were like guess who this is I would
never be able to tell you yeah I think
it's a cool twist on it that's the one
that I'm here for I think that excites
me and we have Mary Elizabeth Winstead
playing at Huntress all I can really say
here is that she looks amazing
I want to be that cross though I want to
be shot by that girl's bow we also have
a Rosie Perez as Renee Montoya she's a
Gotham City police detective she looks
awesome
LJ Basco as Cassandra Cain nothing
really revealed here but Cassandra Cain
is a Batgirl is a back there are many
bad girls there are many bad girls and
also what I know about this character is
that she is extremely qualified in
martial arts I don't know if you can
extremely qualified at martial arts but
basically she kicks ass love back oh and
if it's going with some of the DC Comics
lore it's that she's mute she doesn't
speak Oh
yeah yeah and then we have let's talk
about the guys here the villains I
assume we have Ewan McGregor as black
mask not wearing a black mask no could
be shots is it no Matt maybe an origin
story we're getting here yeah I still or
you don't wanna cover up your mugger say
that's true that's my thing
don't cover up his face don't cover be
safe and I want to talk about um this is
the whole reason I wanted to do this
Chris Messina who is playing Victor says
which if you've seen Victor sighs before
in any of the iterations he is like kind
of hideous and has scars everywhere and
this is like the hottest dude I have
ever seen in my life
you and I have very different variations
on hi no he looks like he listens to a
ton of 21 pilots but maybe that's my
Titan baby I have issues I don't know he
looks like but I'm feeling things he
looks like he gets high in this mom's
basement I'm not here for it I think I'm
a pipe I'm not really sure but I haven't
feeling a ton of feelings about Victor
Zsasz so how are we feeling about the
fact that this is a kick-ass cast of
females and it seems like the men are
the villains I gotta say you know I
don't like to do the Marvel vs. DC thing
because I am a big fan of both but I
think that DC has made such impressive
strides on that front having women
behind the camera having women writing
and then doing this whole thing which is
amazing mm-hmm I know that fans out
there being really harsh on this teaser
this 19 seconds they're kind of tearing
it to shreds I think that they just
wanted to do it a whole episode about I
know but I think they wanted to just
give the fans a little nugget I was not
a massive fan of this teaser a lot of
people are comparing it to an H&M
commercial but I'm excited that we're
getting it just feels a little early it
does kind of look like an advert like
I've had campaigns yeah but yeah like
we're 32 it is like it is I'm assuming
it's a costume test yeah kind of like
what we got with the joaquin phoenix
joker things so it it may not be exactly
what we're gonna see I think it's a good
indicator I do agree it is a little
early because it was a lot of reveals in
that 19 seconds but I think it made me
really excited for a movie that I wasn't
I just was like oh this is coming and
then and where's Batman so my final
question here is that we have that
picture that margot robbie posted on
instagram she's wearing the collar skull
dog tag that says
Bruce as in Bruce Wayne cousin Batman's
real identity so like where is he this
is supposedly a Batman list Gotham does
she know his identity what's going on
let's speculate away what do you think
of that mouthful of a title I think I
love it because I think it's really
Harley Quinn like I'm gonna sue me we're
just gonna keep calling it birds of prey
I was hoping it was gonna be Gotham City
sirens because that was the initial
rumor right floating around all those
years ago I thought that sounded nice
but this is a mouthful well it is
interesting from a journalists
perspective because when you google
birds of prey stuff about actual birds
not this so I don't know if it's
seo-friendly final thoughts are we okay
with this I am mostly okay with this I
need to see more from the actual film I
need to see actual footage but I liked
it I'm okay I think it made me more
excited I obviously loved Harley Quinn
like give me a million Harley Quinn
movies abut these other characters like
seeing them for the first time chris
messina together yeah I'm very okay with
it I'm very okay with it but we want to
hear from you guys let us know what you
think I'm a - cross and where can we
find you at Liana Galera let me know
he's BOTS and we'll talk to you next
time we're okay with it
[Music]